salut c'est jamie et je suis extrêmement
content de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle émission on va partir à la
rencontre de ces martiniquais
guadeloupéens guyanais réunionnais tous
ceux qui à un moment ont dû quitter leur
département d'origine pour vivre loin de
chez eux certains sont aux états unis
d'autres au japon en chine en thaïlande
en allemagne ou en russie on essaiera de
comprendre ce qui les a amenés à partir
loin de chez eux
quelle est leur nouvelle vie et surtout
ce qu'ils aiment dans leur nouveau pays
alors bienvenue on vous emmène en voyage
sur la première
[Musique]
et c'est en allemagne que je vous emmène
aujourd'hui découvrir cynthia danel et
martiniquaise bonjour cynthia
martiniquaise qui vit en allemagne
depuis combien de temps
alors qu'est ce qui t'a amené aussi loin
de la martinique tu es donc dans cette
grande ville de berlin
on va quand même rappeler en cette
période de confinement est liée aux
covit 19 que c'est un petit peu
différent de la france où on est confiné
d'ailleurs j'enregistre dans mon salon
aujourd'hui suite à ce confinement
comment ça se passe en allemagne pour
vous les gens respectent donc cette
autodiscipline on va douiller en en
évitant de sortir si ce n'est pas
nécessaire et indispensable
quelle est l'ambiance en allemagne en ce
moment par rapport à la france où c'est
effectivement un petit peu angoissant ce
qu'on vit de 19 est scandaleux mag vous
le vivez différemment plus sereinement
la martinique
tu la quittes est depuis quelques temps
j'imagine que tu reviens régulièrement
de partants ton métier puisque je
rappelle que tu es hôtesse de l'air
tu as des nouvelles de la famille en
martinique c'est vrai que je suis pas
dépaysé totalement jeu
moi ça va vraiment ce qu'est ce qui te
manque le plus
qu'est ce qui est différent ou
secrètement que le plus à berlin par
rapport à ta vie de martin 15 j'ai tout
à proximité
j'ai tout de manière très simple ce que
tu aimes le plus en allemagne
justement cette accessibilité plein de
choses toutes les communautés sont
représentés ici on peut faire histoire
et ça on va aller voir un concert
d'harmonie
s'il fallait visiter un quoi en
allemagne alors on ira pas tout de suite
parce qu'on on un confinement
on va attendre que ça se termine tout ça
une fois que c'est terminé si on devait
visiter l'allemagne tu nous
conseillerais d'aller où un petit mot
pour les antillo guyanais qui nous
regardent et qui sont en plein
confinement
ou c'est assez anxiogène acier assez
stressant restez chez vous je sais que
pour éradiquer les ententes on prend son
mal en patience on essaye de se
redécouvrir à la maison et essayons de
tirer le positif de cette expérience
particulière
on l'a pas dit au début mais tu
également blogueuse et ouais alors
comment il s'appelle ton blog on ira
jeter un petit coup d'oeil tout à
l'heure écologie de toussieu queen
ça s'appelle tea y avoir jusqu'à point
fr et si vous êtes un homme et là on
ressent bien la martiniquaise qui garde
quand même un milieu avec avec ses
racines promis après le confinement on
ira faire un petit tour en allemagne à
berlin pour découvrir ta belle ville
voilà c'était un petit bout de voyage
avec cynthia en allemagne on se retrouve
très vite pour une nouvelle destination
[Musique]